Hello everybody my name is markiplier ( ¬ ‿ ¬ )
And welcome to Zombie Night Terror
The game where YOU are in charge of the zombies
and YOU get to determine the deadly deeds that they execute
On your behalf or atleast that's what i'm assuming about the game judge by what i saw there
YESS ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Contaminate three humans to kill forteen ( 14 ) more        (☉ロ☉)
* Followed by an evil laugh * (ʘᗝʘ)
So i dont know how to play this game
But i saw the preview for it and it looked super cool,
Like ridiculously cool
Right up my alley and it had this really cool styling to it,
and i love the name, i love the title
( i love you too ⤜(♥ω♥)⤏ )
[ An NPC talking to each other about random shtufff  ]
[ NPC Talking to each other accompanied by Marks beautiful laugh ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) ]
Uh...
no comment
[NPC is still talking (¬_¬)]
oh oh i dont think you should do that (do it  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  )
Man these pixelated girls like to jump
around and shake their boobs ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Thats all i know about this game thus far
( Mark whispering "ok" )
(Mark screams "OH - HO " ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) )
YOU OH YOU Surround em'
Oh JESUS, OH GOOD GOLLY
OH I played a game like this but this is
so much better ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
OH MAN! That guy should've run
Holy shit THAT WAS AWSOME
WHAT WAS THE GAME CALLED?
It was a game like this
And i see u in there ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I see you trying to hide you think you're going to escape me!
well the answer is yes you absolutely
can but I don't want you to. lady,
you seem a lot less panicked than you
should be oh! hello friends where did you
come from
alrighty then I don't know if I did my
job Jesus was that a fountain of blood?
let me try that again because i want to
get the overkill i'm pretty sure I know
how I just got to get the guys on the
outskirts so grab this
boing-boing-boing because i think that
guy in the center already has it he's
already going to be infected
ha maybe  oh oh! maybe don't run that way
No you stupid zombie bitch
can I scroll? oh I can I had no idea!!
Oh bash down that door!! oh break it open!!
oh that's so cool oh you're dead okay well that
sucks for you oh geese!
oh god I had no idea oh oh my apparently
they're too stupid to get through doors (on this level)
but maybe i'll be able to upgrade them
and be able to beat that
oh I love this already!!!!! i really love
this already(yep you heard it mark loves death and zombies be aware)
Jesus that found of blood I did marginally
better but I'm assuming I'm gonna need
some upgrades to be able to get through
everything and that's a big TV show
[NPC Audio] [Mark] What's it doing here? Turn it on [NPC Audio]
[NPC Audio] [Mark] You turn it on [NPC Audio]
[Now back to Mark] Oh what do I do with that
oh hi hello we are coming to live from
downtown this lady reporter has an
amazing voice
we're coming to you live from downtown
where it's believed the contamination
started kicking babies considered to be
healthy(again more reasons he is secretly evil)
well that's convenient for me because
that vindicates me of what I was doing
oh geez ok then locals at the scene
believe the bizarre changes in populus
from a defective batch of home-cooked
drugs
our investigation is ongoing stay with
us April Fox ZNT news alrighty then
well that doesn't sound good  uh oh, ah jeez
Oh God hey come on man don't be like
that
you need to relax "Oh fuck my feel so ragged...
I've been munching on tainted Romero"
uh yeah lady lady I'm sorry lady I feel
bad oh jeez oh goodness
gracious welp
my job is done ? I can't scroll to the
oh yes i can i can give them
instructions this is so cool i sorry I'm
freaking out i just love this a lot
breakdown that freakin door
hell yeah you mean I could instructed
them to get the guy in the in the
dumpster
oh I could've done that would have been
great spread the junkie plague by
killing 22 humans kill every human
without losing any zombies
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to do
that okay so we got guys coming in the
front so bap
oh shit so that guy can take care of my
zombo's oh jeez but there's more
over there
oh hell yeah okay I'm gonna restart this
let me reboot so i need to get
that guy on my side before he can beat
up any zombies oh you don't feel so good
oh jeez he feels real bad alrights so you in
the supply closet you and you this is,
this is the stuff but yes and then I got
more you with the gun you with that and
then does anybody else have a weapon you
might have a weapon I'm gonna get
you too go up you go up oh geez
yes yes kill the all kill the all
ahh oh jeez he ducked so the girl got
killed oh Jeez what a dick go down this way is
forward to the show that yeah there we
go okay starting to shibbity shop our way
down that way and so then we did that oh
no i didn't know i shouldn't waste it
ow
Oh BAM bitch ahh jeez I lost a god dammit
hey i just don't have all the guys
congregated oh that's because they're
not going down get em get em all their
dead wow already then
go up there, go there
oh this is so cool i like this so don't
no that's an .... oh Jesus don't do
that don't go up there how did that guy
get how did that get zombie oh did he
just have a bad to take a drug it wasn't
supposed to but oh jeez now my guys are
gonna win because they don't have enough
well that's not good that also is not
good okay i guess we're done here
thank you bring on the fountain of blood
yeah I ain't the perfect assassin but I'm
handsome so that's a consolation prize
oh hello who the heck are you got to
keep working on this... I'm gonna let them talk
[NPC Incomprehensible]
I don't think this qualifies as a scientific process till now you're which
"Here we are, my next random recipe ahem improved formula is nearly, is nearly
ready"
bra bro bra bra oh boy I don't think you're
going to live much longer to be able to
stop all this so we gotta get rid of
that thing gotta break the generator so
we can get in there and get this
improved recipe so I'm to believe but
I'm to believe this this this stupid
sack of shit right here
oh oh he needs to be, you better run
you're not gonna run fast enough
are you
hey your a dick, ok then you might want to
shoot faster dude nope too late, Oh
oh-no he's dead jeez Scoob what is that oh
What?.. How do i how do i do the Overlord you go
that way
oh ho ho! Whoa what the Freak happen to you
is that all you do you just sprout a weird
ballsack legs and then you tell people
which way to go
alrighty then dr. Romero your days might
be numbered because this is getting
weird and I like it so before they fall
in that pit i need to get one of these
doodads to go the other way so i need to
slam these guys
hey go that way right hey there hey you
might want to go over there as much
better over there
Hey look at that stuff yeah i thought so
I thought as much as that thing right
you guys did good was sacrifices zombie
to get more DNA okay how about this guy
but she is
I'm sorry Larry oh god I'm sorry
anyway it was for a good cause I suppose
maybe no idea i love it i love it what's
next create an epidemic and killed 25
humans challenge find the secret drug
stash
oh really well where is the secret wow
this is the sprawling level the secret
drug stash is that it
ok so i can't even can't even though
cool it's like up boozle what I have to
do is I have to make this guy go that
way
hey Malcolm hey
ok you guys got that right now
Oh burger number ok goodbye
okay so I need of all down there first
and a staging area before they break
that door down like mindless idiots ok
so if i go down this way I will be able
to get the secret stash but it looks
like there's land mines i'm not mistaken
those are a hundred percent landmines
but if I go this way I think this will
work but they're going to do this but I
definitely don't want to go that way
because that's landmines again I should
probably collect more before i go there
though that would be a good idea
yeah let's do that yeah let's go up
first get more ruin the selfie party get
back down there collect that three
whatever that is I want that number
three and then do whatever I need to to
show that lady is going to open the door
to a neighbor well well sorry i love the
guy in the Commodore just want that
three give me that three bring that
wow this wall shit okay well least it
wasn't awful enough of a fall to kill me
so i can get down there and that's good
and then we can break that door won't be
able to go to do don't you guys worry
about thing I don't want to deal with
the guy with the gun i want to get down
here deal with these guys and then I you
know have a good don't go through that
door do okay
booski are like you're in a bit of
trouble all he's dead oh no oh god no
hand there have been to step up dude hey
dude ah dude dude dude
oh jeez they're two stacked-up now(he will now kill 4/5 of the zombie population)
they're just act up
o God Almighty Ahmose og's I'm not gonna
make it
oh geez I'm not gonna make it yeah
oh geez have a few ppl park and they
made it holy shit that lady should have
moved it but I made it to the secret
drug stash
that's what's important alrighty then so
we got that I don't know why there was a
number three there but apparently it was
not something that I actually needed but
I got enough of these guys to be able to
get through and then get through this
level almost Ahmose are up here so what
I need to do
is I need to get the guys with guns and(make them ordenary zombies who cant shoot)
see there's a five and ten and one Sammy
I don't understand through here break
that one
oh that's gonna break down oh that's the
number required to break it down okay
first I'm gonna get you oh no hope
so three you're gonna break that down
nice oh IC ok so i need to put this guy
here they go that way
hey guys go that hey know it's dangerous
it's dangerous
he's a safety worker this guy's a
goddamn hero with his pulsating balls
hello we're here now yeah you all are
scared(but join me in the next world power) I don't think cuddling in a ball
is going to help anybody in this
situation
nope didn't help you wow that's a lot of
blood hey hey stop that
hey hey you know you don't feel so good
do you know you left the door open like
a dingus to write so I need to get rid
of this guy to get people wait no not
that guy oh wait like this guy that this
guy that way that way we're not done
oh that would have been a much easier
way to go about this i'm an idiot I'm
dumped up big gold um ok but I did it
yeah I killed everybody food
Jesus and I got the challenge I don't
know what that did but I got it right so
what's next
oh jeez okay here's the safe we got to
open if we get paid careful with the
explosive mix will get that safe open
easily but it's really unstable
I'll treated like a rare butterfly wow
my oh oh jesus oh god why do you do that(it was the butterfly they're on the zom side)
that's something I can use to turn my
zombies into a horrifying explosive
zombies ok but anyway i am going to RUN AWAY
pause this here because i'm all out of
that was fun bye then(lets let the world recover for now)
be gone
more of this so that's exactly what I'm
gonna do
I can't wait to get more of it seems
really cool it's a weird mixture of like
a puzzle game because you have to be
your still here?
also it's just a brutal rampage of
go away shoo
play more of this
go away
let me know what you think of this down below in the pits of hell
as always(you should now by know)
in the next invasion of earth join or die
(It's actually "I will see you in the next video. Buh-bye!)